we had part one of this next story
yesterday
and now it's actually gotten even more
interesting uh right-wing propaganda
network
newsmax has now been forced to debunk
its own election lies due to a legal
threat from the voting machine company
smartmatic which
both demanded a retraction and reserved
its right to take legal action
yesterday i told you that after six
weeks of spreading all sorts of debunked
lies about election fraud
lou dobbs on fox aired a clarifying
segment
saying basically none of that stuff i
said was true newsmax has now done the
exact same thing so let's take a look at
uh this is anchor john tobacco that's
his real name as far as i know
issuing clarifications and the title of
this clip should really be we don't want
to get sued
since election day uh various guests
attorneys and elected officials have
appeared on newsmax and offered opinions
and claims about smartmatic
and dominion systems both companies that
offer voting software in the us
and newsmax would like to clarify its
news coverage and note
that it has not reported as true certain
claims made about these companies
there are several facts our viewers and
readers should be aware of
newsmax has found no evidence that
either dominion or smartmatic
owns the other or has any business
association
with each other we have no evidence that
dominion uses smartmatic software or
vice versa
no evidence has been offered that
dominion or smartmatic used software
or reprogrammed software that
manipulated votes in the 2020 election
smartmatic has stated that its software
was only used in the 2020 election in
los angeles
was not used in any battleground state
contested by the trump campaign
newsmax has no evidence to the contrary
dominion has stated the company has no
ownership relationship with the pelosi
family the feinstein family
the clinton family hugo chavez or the
government of venezuela
neither dominion nor smartmatic has any
relationship with george soros
smartmatic is a u.s company and not
owned by the venezuelan government
hugo chavez or any foreign official or
entity
smartmatic states that it has no
operations in venezuela
while the company did election projects
in venezuela from 2004
to 2017 it states it was never founded
by hugo chavez nor did it have a corrupt
relationship with him or the venezuelan
government
for more on this please go to our
website at newsmax.com
if that isn't a guy being held hostage
by the company's lawyers i don't know
what is
so just like with yesterday's fox clip
the news max anchor says there's no
connection between smartmatic and
dominion
votes weren't manipulated by the voting
machines the machines in question
weren't used in battleground states
there's no connection to nancy pelosi
or hugo chavez or the clintons or
venezuela
george soros has nothing to do with this
and it's really quite stunning
and just like i said yesterday lots of
the news max
audience will hear this but they're not
going to believe it because
they will believe that the newsmax host
was forced to do this
which he was essentially because of the
legal demand letter that was received
but i'll actually even go further
how do you make up for five weeks of
spreading disinformation
seven weeks almost at this point
hundreds of times
with this one segment this is the lou
dogs
segment similar to uh what we just saw
on newsmax this was
yesterday on fox business take a look
lots of opinions about the integrity of
the election the irregularities of
mail-in
voting of election voting machines and
voting software
one of the companies is smartmatic and
we reached out to one of the leading
authorities on open source software for
elections eddie perez for his insight
and views
eddie is the global director of tech
development at the open source
election technology institute we ask him
for his assessment of smartmatic
and recent claims about the company
have you seen any evidence that
smartmatic software was used to flip
votes anywhere in the us
in this election i have not seen any
evidence that smartmatic software was
used to
delete change alter
anything related to vote tabulation
smartmatic says its software was never
used outside of la county in 2020.
do you know whether or not that's true
that is my understanding
smartmatic uh functioned as the contract
manufacturer
for the los angeles county voting system
and that was a customized system that
was effectively built to the county's
order
i am not aware of them having any other
direct customers relationships with
election officials in the united states
what about smartmatic and dominion do
you know if they're related
whether one owns the other whether
dominion uses smartmatic software
both dominion and smartmatic have
individually and respectively put out
uh very clear statements from their
corporate headquarters
each of them indicating they are
independent companies they are not
related to each other
it is my understanding that neither one
of them has an ownership stake in the
other
or anything like that so almost
identical information is being conveyed
in the two videos clearly they don't
want to face the lawsuits that they were
being threatened with
but i just don't know how one two minute
fact check
once makes up for spreading this stuff
for going on two months
but of course they're doing the absolute
minimum
to either avoid being sued or to
mitigate damage if indeed they are sued
that's all they care about now here's a
bonus clip for you this is this is great
uh host sebastian gorka
is interviewing the my pillow guy mike
lindell
and mike lindell starts going into the
voter fraud conspiracies
and seb gorka actually cuts him off
because he clearly has been advised we
can't keep repeating this stuff take a
look
i believe in this president but and i'll
tell you what
nobody realizes i mean what a miracle we
had on election night
at 11 15 you know you talked about all
this fraud
doctor the the the biggest fraud is the
dominion machines
and at 11 15 on election night
our great president because i don't want
to discuss
mike mike we're not we're not going to
get into the minutiae of the details
i want to ask you because this show is
about courage
so seb gorka they're desperate to get
away from that topic before they end up
with another
legal threat so the headlines go on the
front
every day for six weeks and then they
put a correction on the back page
once that's the equivalent of what
they're doing here
fox news was told in the letter from the
smartmatic lawyers
you need to claim there wasn't fraud
with the same amount of frequency and
intensity as the number of times you
claimed there was fraud
clearly fox news hasn't done that
clearly newsmax hasn't done that for now
but my concern is less legal than it is
about the reality
that the damage has been done by their
harping on this stuff for six weeks they
may get sued anyway because their lives
were so egregious
but the problem is that when you do this
for six or seven weeks
the correction is irrelevant you're not
going to change any of your own
audience's mind because they understand
that you were clearly forced to do this
and that what you said for six weeks is
the truth as they see it will oan have
to do the same i don't know we're
keeping an eye on that
but this is already a sign that as i've
been saying for several weeks now
the right-wing media landscape for the
next several years
is going to be very interesting
regardless of what donald trump does
and we'll be following it and we'll have
more of these clips on the david pakman
show instagram page which you can find
at david pakman show